[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is biner and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about the
impact of social media on our
friends let's talk about social media
and connection as we reflect on our high
school days it's hard not to notice how
social media has transformed the way we
connect with our friends platforms like
Instagram Snapchat and Facebook have
provided us with new avenues for
maintaining relationships beyond the
confines of the school walls through
these digital spaces we we've shared
moments of Joy celebrated achievements
and supported each other during
challenging times the pressure to Conor
however it's important to unn knowledge
the pressure that social media can exert
on us the need to present an idealized
version of ourselves often leads to
comparations and unrealistic
expectations as we scroll through the
perfectly cated feeds of our peers many
of us felt the weight of fitting into a
certain mold this quest for validation
through likes and comments sometimes
overshadowed the authentic connection we
could have fered
offline navigating challenges and
building resilence in the mindset of the
social media frenzy we encountered
challenges that tested our emotional
resilence cyber bullying online
conflicts and the fear of missing out
post hardless demanded a
delicate balance between staying
connected and protecting our mental
well-being learning to distinguish
between genuine interactions and The
Superficial allor of the online world
became crucial for maintaining healthy
friendships and a positive Health
image let's talk about creating a
healthy digital lifestyle despite its
complexities social media has also
empowered us to became more aware of
digital well-being we learned to set
boundaries cultivate meaning file online
relationships and use these platforms to
spread positivity and awareness many of
us in the initiated discussions about
mental health authenticity and the
importance of disconnecting to engage
more fuy in the present
moment the changing dynamics of
friendship one of the most significant
impacts of social media on our
friendships was the shift in how we
perceived and mentioned relationships
visual interactions often blurred the
lines between closeness and
superficiality the constant exposure to
serated highlights of our friends lives
sometimes led to a sense of distance and
disconnection challenging the
authenticity of the bonds we had
nurtured over the
years shaping identity and
self-expression on the flip side social
media provided us with a platform for
self-expression and exploration of our
identities from sharing our hobbies and
passions to advocating for causes close
to our hearts these platforms Amplified
our voices and enabled us to create
communities around shared interests many
of us found solace in connecting with
like-minded individuals fostering a
sense of belonging that transcended
physical
boundaries building digital citizenship
and
awareness our experiences with soci
social media during High School
instilled in us a sense of
responsibility to be mindful digital
citizens we became more aware of the
implications of our online actions and
phasing the importance of respectful
communication ethical sharing and
safeguarding privacy understanding the
impact of our digital footprint became
crucial in maintaining trust and fering
healthy friendships both online and
offline the influence of social media on
future
relationships as we transition as we
transitioned from high school to the
next chapter for our lives the influence
of social media on our friendships
continue to shape the way we approach
relationships our experiences with
navigating the complexities of these
digital platforms taught us valuable
lessons that we carried forward
influencing the way we interacted with
ours and built Connections in the
college and professional
fears fostering a balanced approach
looking back we realize that finding a
balance between the benefits and
drawbacks of social media was crucial
learning the prioritize face-to-face
interactions establishing healthy screen
time habits and fostering genuine
connections beyond the digital real
became essential for preserving the
authenticity of our friendships and
nurturing a sense of
belonging cultivating empathy and
understanding through our experiences
with social media we developed a deeper
sense of empathy and understanding
recognizing the impact of our words and
actions online we learn to approach
virtual interactions with kindness and
consideration fostering a culture of
support and inclusivity within our
digital communities these lessons in
empathy translated into our everyday
interactions nurturing a more comp iate
and understanding approach to our
friends and
relationships let's talk something about
harnessing the positive potential of
social media despite the challenges
social media has also served as a
catalyst for positive change we
witnessed the power of these Platforms
in mobilizing communities raising
awareness about important issues and
fostering Global Connections that
transcend geographical boundaries those
collaborative efforts and shared
initiatives we've seen how social media
can be harnessed to create meaningful
impacts whether through fundraising for
charitable causes organizing community
events or advocating for social justice
and environmental
sustainability the evolving landscape of
digital interactions the ever evolving
landscape of digital interactions
constantly introduces new trends our and
Technologies
reshaping the way we engage with social
media from the rise of influencer
culture the emergence of new
communication platforms we' adopted to
these changes recognizing the importance
of crucial critical thinking and
responsible engagement our experiences
in navigating these shifts have
highlighted the significance of staying
informed and mindful in a fast-paced and
dynamic online
environment lessons for the future
generation as we look back on our high
school experiences we recognize the
importance of imparting valuable lessons
for the future generation we aim to
foster a culture of digital literacy
resilence and empathy encouraging young
individuals to approach social media
with a critical eye and an understanding
of its potential impact by promoting
responsible usage and ethical engagement
we hope to create a safer and more
inclusive online space for generations
to
come in conclusion our school memories
our high school memories sorry are
interviewed with the profound influence
of social media on our friendships and
personal growth as we navigate the ever
evolving digital landscape let's
remember the importance of fostering
genuine connections promoting empathy
and utilizing these platforms as
Catalyst for positive change by
harnessing the positive potential of
social media while remaining mindful of
its complexities we can create a digital
environment that Fosters meaningful
relationships and nurtures a sense of
community and understanding thank you so
much for joining us on this episode of
high school memories it's been an
incredible journey and we so glad you
came along for the ride until next time
take
[Music]
care